this is what federal ndp leader jagmeet
singh was met with as he left
peterborough on tuesday a loud group
yelling obscenities as singh made his
way to a vehicle these videos are now
going viral on social media and the
incident is making national headlines
sing now saying he received death
threats what i really want to highlight
there was folks that were saying some
really bad you know some really horrible
things they were saying some folks are
saying you know i hope you die and
things along that nature
a lot of aggression and violence in
terms of the behavior and demeanor thing
spoke again to reporters on thursday
afternoon for me personally and for my
staff i would say that was one of the
most intense
threatening insulting and physically
there's a that feeling of intense threat
but i'm not personally surprised about
that nor worried about that i've
experienced worse
is your staff worried are the people
around you worried yes they are worked
that should never happen uh that's
intolerable in our system uh for anybody
not just not just the leader of a
political party zing was in town tuesday
to throw his support behind peterborough
kawartha ndp candidate jen dexbid in the
upcoming provincial election and while
things got out of hand outside there was
no police presence which has come into
question by many on social media in a
tweet peterborough police stated they
weren't even aware that singh was in
town on tuesday despite multiple emails
global news was not granted an interview
with peterborough police on thursday
instead the service released a prepared
video statement your actions and belief
systems are reprehensible unconscionable
and in some cases criminal federal
police service will use every
investigative tool possible to deal with
your actions
we've received a complaint in regards to
the incident and we are actively
investigating global news also reached
out to dec for comment but didn't hear
back by deadline meanwhile peterborough
kawartha conservative mp michelle
ferrari says there are other ways to get
your point across without using hate
speech or threats i condem
hate speech and violence in any form
full stop protesting is part of
democracy right i mean that's and we're
all elected officials and so it's
important that people are able to
execute their right to voice their
concerns
but the reality is you can't harass
people you can't name call go after
policy do a constructive method to get
involved in politics ferrari tells
global news she reached out to sing the
show support for him and to say the
incident isn't what peterborough stands
for
as for singh in a tweet following the
incident he stated peterborough i love
you don't worry i'll be back march into
global news